en un panorama de ausencia de mayorías
absolutas en las elecciones generales
del 23 de Julio en España cada grupo del
parlamento tiene el poder de ser clave
para formar gobierno de ahí la
importancia de este debate a 7 donde los
portavoces de los mayores partidos del
país tuvieron 125 minutos Para proponer
alternativas o defender su recorrido
Pese a que había siete participantes el
encuentro fue mucho más sosegado Y claro
que el cara a cara del lunes entre el
presidente del gobierno Pedro Sánchez y
el líder de la oposición feijó los
mismos cuatro bloques temáticos economía
donde los datos fueron los protagonistas
con los grupos pequeños haciendo
propuestas y los más grandes
recriminándose en políticas sociales se
habló de las leyes más señaladas de esta
legislatura como la ley del empleo la de
vivienda la ley trans o la ley del solo
sí es Sí además de acusaciones de vox a
la migración asociándola con los
recientes disturbios en Francia por
ejemplo política territorial y por
primera vez con representación de grupos
nacionalistas e independentistas vascos
y catalanes hablo de Cataluña donde es
que la República han afirmó que lo único
que pretenden es poder votar un
referendo de Independencia el bloque más
incómodo para los dos partidos líderes
en las encuestas cerró este debate a
siete el único donde compartieron
espacio los posibles socios de psoe y PP
Box y sumar que podrían ser la llave
para ayudar a estos dos partidos a
formar gobierno si los sondeos están en
lo cierto y ningún grupo obtiene los 176
escaños necesarios para gobernar en
solitario empezó así la cuenta atrás
para estas elecciones generales del 23
de julio y el 19 de julio habrá un
último debate Eso sí a tres con Pedro
Sánchez por el partido socialista
Santiago abascal por el de ultraderecha
vox y Yolanda Díaz por la formación
progresista sumar este debate no contará
con la participación del líder de la
oposición Alberto Núñez feijo que
rechazo a participar